>>Sparky: The Wednesday afternoon Android
Developer's Office Hours Hangout. This is
your EMEA edition coming to you from Munich,
Germany. That's me, I'm Sparky. And we've
got Matt and Nick and, coming from London
UK. And we're here to answer for you any questions
or address any topics of discussion that you
want to have about developing apps for Android.
And with that, let's see who's in the hangout.
Nobody's in the hangout. Crickets chirp, chirp,
chirp. We had some technical difficulties
today. So we got off to a little bit of a
late start. And it could take people a little
while to catch up to us.
While we're waiting for some people to join
us in the hangout, perhaps we can turn to
the moderator and see what question we have
cued up. Well, I heard somebody ding. Did
anybody come in? Not yet.
>>Nick: I think that's just me inviting a
bunch of people to come join us.
>>Sparky: Excellent. Great.
[pause]
Let me come up with the old Moderator and
see what people have asked.
Martin S. from northwest UK. So I guess this
will be a question for Matt and Nick to answer.
List detail page scenario in single pane mode,
activity hosts the list fragment. User selects
from list. Should the detail fragment be displayed
by replacing the list fragment in the same
activity, or should detail page be launched
in its own activity. Pretty classic multi
fragment, multi activity question.
The way we usually solve this in our application
templates is, when you're running this app
on a large format device like a ten inch tablet,
then we would recommend putting two things
side by side. So you have your detail and
your list in the same place. And then you
run that same app on a smaller device like
a phone. You should probably completely swap
out the list view for the detail view. And
the easiest way to program this is to put
the list in one fragment and the detail in
another. And generally speaking when you completely
clear away one set of UI and replace it completely
with another, that's kind of an activity change.
And that's probably gonna be the cleanest
and easiest way to do it. And as I noted in
my response in the moderator, I think that
by making it a new activity, is going to be
the easiest way to get the right semantics
for navigation using the back button.
[pause]
You guys wanna comment on that right now?
Did I pretty much cover it?
>>Matt: [inaudible] answer.
>>Nick: Yeah. Can't talk about it.
>>Sparky: We have been joined in the hangout
by Jonathan ward. Hello Jonathan. Do you have
anything on your mind about Android development?
[pause]
>>Jonathan: Well this is the first hangout
that I'm doing so I'm not sure if my microphone
is working. Can you hear me?
>>Nick: Loud and clear.
>>Sparky: We hear you.
>>Jonathan: Fantastic. I didn't have any particular
question. I just wanted to join the conversation
as my first developers office hours, to see
what's up.
>>Nick: Ah. Well, welcome.
>>Sparky: Yeah, welcome.
>>Matt: Where are you based?
>>Jonathan: I'm actually based in the US.
>>Matt: Uh-huh.
>>Sparky: Well then you'll be able to get
your fill of hangouts because the Mountain
View team will be having another hangout just
like this one in eight or nine hours.
>>Jonathan: Great.
>>Sparky: So what's on your mind? What are
you developing these days?
>>Jonathan: Well, I'm developing a music application
and actually one of the things that I'm trying
to debug today is, view pager seems to not
update fragments when its underlying adapter
gets notified of a data set change. I don't
know if you've run into that issue.
>>Sparky: Hmm. I generally duck the whole
data set change issue entirely by using only
loaders. [chuckles]
>>Jonathan: [laughs]
>>Nick: That's my advice.
>>Jonathan: Mm-hm.
>>Nick: and what I would say as well is sometimes
you need to make sure is, is your adapter
attaining stable IDs? 'Cause basically there's
a few optimizations in view pager.
>>Jonathan: Mm-hm.
>>Nick: Where it'll try not to reload data
that it thinks it's already loaded it.
>>Jonathan: Mm-hmm.
>>Nick: I think it's the, is it the ID it
uses to work out if it's the same pages you've
loaded, it's already loaded?
>>Matt: I can't remember. I kind of remember
when I was doing some research with this I
ended up having to do a little bit of trickery
around it in terms of a sync task kicking
in, but I think why it did was using the view
holder design pattern to kind of insure that
it would be the view holder that would update
from the cursor and then update the views
that it needed to do.
>>Jonathan: Mm-mm.
>>Matt: so that may be a kind of different
way of looking at it. Yeah there is a lot
of optimizations at the ISO view pager.
>>Sparky: If you're looking into any of that
sort of view pager, fragment adapter sort
of thing, definitely do be at least passingly
familiar with the fragment samples in the
[screeching noise] in the API demos. Sample
[unintelligible] They implement a lot of interesting
fragment behaviors in there. Things like view
pager combined with a tab manager. Fragments
in a view pager each with its own list view.
Each recording its own state. They have the
throttle loader which takes a list fragment
and fills it, I think it's like one row per
second or something like that. And you can
just kinda get in there and see different
ways that the Android engineers have implemented
activities using these different APIs.
So API demos definitely should be in everybody's
repertoire as a great go-to place for reference
code. It's not the end all be all, but it's
got a lot of good samples in it.
>>Jonathan: Great.
>>Sparky: I see we've been joined in the hangout
also by Alejandro and Emil. And just now by
Markus. So, welcome guys. Welcome to the hangout.
Do you have any questions about Android development?
Or, what's on your mind.
>>Markus: I just wanted to say, I heard you
talk about the page switcher. What are they
called? I actually use it for fragments. I
had some problems. 'Cause I actually had fragments
containing them. I had fragments inside fragments.
That's my [unintelligible].
>>Sparky: That's a no no.
>>Markus: Yeah, exactly. So I ended up making
like a lightweight version of fragments. Which
only pretty much has a new, and not even a
life cycle. But it works pretty well actually.
>>Sparky: Cool, how did you do that?
>>Markus: Well, it's a list I made from scratch.
It's a pretty small class. I might put in
an app somewhere, at some point. But not yet.
But it's pretty simple task. It's a task that
[unintelligible].
>>Sparky: So, did you, did you use any of
the Android framework source code from source
at Android.com. or did you roll those all
yourself.
>>Markus: Well, I mean this is a really small
class. It's like it's, I just pretty much
borrowed some concepts like how do you, I
think it has this ability and it has some
help [unintelligible] to—
>>Nick: I was going to say, it's actually
a view to that extent? It's like a custom
view basically?
>>Markus: No, no, no. it's more like a fragment.
>>Nick: OK.
>>Markus: But I want to see if I can put it
up somewhere.
>>Nick: Yeah, definitely for a [gist] like
that.
>>Sparky: Yeah, that's very cool. We love
to hear what you guys do when you take the
framework and run with it. And take it in
your own direction. I guess some of the more
popular places that people tend to put up
their contributions to the code base are in
the code.google.com or in GitHub, I would
say is probably the top two? What do you think
Nick? Matt?
>>Nick: Yeah, I'd say GitHub is generally
pretty popular these days.
>>Matt: Yeah, I think that's the one I've
seen most of the time. The source code being
stuck up on GitHub.
>>Sparky: I notice that's where the mighty
ActionBarSherlock hangs out. [chuckles]
>>Matt: [chuckles] Yes.
>>Sparky: Alright. Who else is in the call?
Emil. What's on your mind?
>>Emil: Hi. I think you saw my question on
the moderator about text use disappearing
when rotated?
>>Sparky: Oh yes, I was trying to write some
code to prove that out and I didn't really
get anywhere. I kind of started too late.
>>Emil: Yeah, I wanted to respond again, but
I didn't see a way to respond again in moderator.
Just edited my own column. Yeah, it's really
just [unintelligible] I mean, I wrote to the
canvas with a matrix and run base axis and
the text just disappears only when it's two
lines. When it's one line it works fine.
>>Sparky: Very interesting.
>>Emil: Well, more than one line. Three lines
probably doesn't work either. I have no idea
why. I mean I can do a work around by drawing
texture bitmap first. But that's just, bad.
>>Sparky: That's kind of what canvas drawing
is though, isn't it? I mean—
>>Emil: Well, yeah, but drawing it through
bitmap before rotating.
>>Sparky: Yeah, I, this is not a particular
specialty of mine. So I would suggest take
your code fragment and put it on stack overflow
and see what the community says. And as I
said in moderator, share with me the URL,
and I'll try to find some time to dig into
it myself. But I would bet you that somebody
out there in the community can answer that
question way faster than I could even get
to it.
>>Emil: Yeah. OK. Yeah, I'll probably do that.
Thanks.
>>Sparky: Yeah. Oh, we've lost Alejandro.
>>Markus: I just wanted to say, I [unintelligible]
to [unintelligible] class. Chuck.
>>Sparky: Mm. Hey, look at that. We have a
link from GitHub. Cool. Alright, thanks Markus.
If no-one else has anything that you wanna
talk about right away, I will go back into
the Moderator. And see what else we've got
cued up. OK.
Just see, huh. Were you about to say something?
>>Nick: No, I'm just having a look at the
gist that Markus threw out there. Which he,
has the code pasted into the G plus comments
as well. And, very interesting. I see what
you mean about it being a lightweight fragment.
>>Matt: Yeah.
>>Sparky: You can do a lot in two lines of
code, huh? [chuckles]
[feedback noises]
OK, the next question from Juno Gonsalves
from Portugal. "Advanced NFC support and documentation
is not the best. Is there any good book to
look at?" Actually, I think I have seen a
book about Android NFC. But I don't recall
the title of it. Maybe try looking in the
Android developers forum and see if someone
is talking about it in there. And there are
developers who discuss on—"For example I
was trying to talk in high data rate mode
with an NFCD tag and concluded the stack does
not support this."
Again, not really my specialty. I would say
if you really want the definitive source,
you sound pretty sophisticated. And I would
say maybe dig into source code. There's probably
some answers in there.
[pause]
Next. "Can I make clickable drawables inside
text view? Drawable created using html.imagetter
from images downloaded from web. I want to
be able to zoom the images." Didn't, Nick,
didn't you and Rich talk about this last week?
>>Nick: Yeah, I think we covered this one.
>>Sparky: Is this the same one? I don't think
it was. I thought I cleaned it out. I seem
to recall your answer was "No, you can't."
Is that right?
>>Nick: Yeah.
>>Sparky: You can make the whole text view
clickable. But you can't really assign a separate
click region inside it. But you could still—
>>Matt: I haven't tried that. That's not something
I've done. I think if you're going to try
to do it, you'd have to wrap the image in
an a-clasp. But then you'd have nothing to
kind of hook that up to get it to click. So
I don't think you could do it.
[pause]
>>Sparky: "It would be cool if Google Now
integrated with Google Events. IE, who's coming
to event name, and read out a list of guest
responses and or show the list. Are Google
planning on allowing developers to produce
custom cards from a Now feature?" That would
be a forward looking statement about something
where nothing has been announced. And I'm
afraid we can't say anything on the topic.
So, take that as neither a confirmation nor
a denial. Simply a lack of answer.
>> Nick: I'll just say, one question which
is from the G plus comments. So Michael Back.
Hi Michael if you're following along. And
he says he's been using the most excellent—sorry
that's my words, not his—tutorial, on Android
training about using bitmaps and LIU caches
and all that good stuff to make sure you don't
get out of memory issues. And very observantly
he noticed the Friday review last week. And
some of the teammates said that there was
going to be an update to that class. And he's
wondering if it's still recommended to use
that training class as is if an update's already
in the works. So I say, it's you know, techniques
are still valid. They've just been slightly
improved and polished a bit more. And if you
wanna take a look at that. If you actually
go to the Google IO application from this
year, from 2012. If you search the code at
google.com and search for IO sched, it's IO,
S-C-H-E-D. Most of the application has been
open sourced now. And actually includes a
lot of the improvement. That's where our team
was kind of like working on stuff. And like,
squashing bugs. And actively improving the
code. So if you take a look in IO sched you
can actually get an early look as it were.
Of the updated versions. I'd say check that
out. But you know, the basic version in the
training course is still valid.
Cool. We are joined by Lucas. Lucas of Pattern
fame, I believe.
>>Lucas: Yep.
>>Nick: Has everyone seen Lucas' app? Pattern.
P-A-T-T-E-R-N is a very cool app for game
and very nice wallpapers for your phones and
tablets.
>>Lucas: Can you hear me?
>>Nick: Yeah.
>>Lucas: OK. I don't have a room here at the
office. [laughs] So I have to walk around.
[laughter]
>>Nick: Right. Very illegal. You're illegal.
>>Lucas: Yeah, I work for Mozilla. So I'm
at the Mozilla office in London. So all the
rooms are booked. So I just got curious about
the developer office hours. So here I am.
[laughter]
>>Sparky: So instead of hanging out, you're
kind of walking out.
>>Lucas: Yeah, walking around.
>>Nick: Boy, you make me feel dizzy.
>>Sparky: Well it's good to have you in the
hangout.
>>Nick: Yeah, just here to say hi and see
what's going on.
[laughter]
>>Sparky: So do you wanna share with us a
little bit of what you do in Mozilla?
>>Lucas: OK, so I work on Firefox for Android
pretty much. So last year we, so the initial
version of Firefox for Android was based on
the same technologies then, the best of version.
So Zillow, I don't know if you're familiar
with it, but Zillow based stuff. But we were
having a lot of performance problems because
of that. So it was a very chunky library.
So on devices with slow file systems, the
library would just take ages to load. So on
some devices we would have like startup times
of like 30 seconds. So it was a bit ridiculous.
So we decided to rewrite the whole app. The
whole front end. Anyway. So since October.
So a month ago we released the first version
of what we called "native Firefox for Android."
Which is in practice, Firefox backhand. Which
means getcode rendering engine, but with native
Android front end.
>>Nick: How do you handle [inaudible] is all,
is all engine?
>>Lucas: Do you mean extensions and stuff?
>>Nick: Yeah.
>>Lucas: So, we are like, independently of
what we're doing, like Mozilla is moving for,
to a more API based kind of thing instead
of the zillow term is called, it's like overlay.
So overlay is like pretty much messing with
the UI from the add-on. So you can't add menu
items and stuff. So we're moving from that
to a more API based thing so we have a shallow
scrape API to add menu items. So it doesn't
matter really what kind of technology is behind
the UI. So you can still do things like add
a menu item. Add a context menu item. All
those things. But through a more controlled
API. So what you cannot do anymore is zillow
overlay stuff. Which is because it's not true
anymore. But we still have a support where
[audio cuts out]-- fine with the Firefox [inaudible].
So. Yeah. There's a bit of, like, certain
amount of work to adapt add-ons. But it's
not too much. So yeah, so we're right now,
we're working on the tablet version of Firefox
for Android. It will be released very soon.
And also native and stuff. So it was a very
good exercise of other responsive design stuff.
And all the—so yeah. All the stuff that
Android gives you. So it was an interesting
thing. Android is not a small app. As you
can imagine. So yeah. That, I mean, we have
like nine, ten versions of the same icon everywhere
because [laughs] it's kind of a ridiculous
amount of assets. But yeah, it's worth it
just to keep it like looking good on any type
of device, right?
>>Nick: So it's a singule APK?
>>Lucas: Yeah, it's a singule APK. Yeah. And
it's a, go on--
>>Nick: All built in London?
>>Lucas: No, no. Yeah, we are like, spread
out. Mostly we are in the US. But, the office
in London is quite new. So we're just like
two people in this team here. So. The office
opened in April. So it's quite new.
>>Nick: Cool.
>>Lucas: And as you've mentioned my spare
time project is Pattern. Just to start a wallpaper
app. For like that grabs all the patterns
from Color Lovers. IF you don't know this
website it's really cool. It's a very nice
community. You can create patterns. Color
palettes and stuff. And so, I just thought
it would be fun to have an app that grabs
all those patterns like, it's a lot of stuff
being created every day. So it's more like,
more than 200,000 patterns. So it's a lot
of stuff. And also I wanted to have an opportunity
to use Android API since I don't have a chance
to use it at work. So, it's kind of a more
like a learning experience than anything else.
>>Sparky: Cool. You get to take a little vacation
from Mozilla and run Chrome for a time.
[laughter]
>>Nick: One of the reasons I like it is that
as you were stating before, with Firefox,
is their response to design aspects. Like
I think you did a nice job customizing your
logo for different size devices. I've had
it on my phone, and on my seven inch tablet
and on my ten inch tablet. And it really kind
of alters its presentation to take advantage
of screen space. And I think you've done a
nice job there.
>>Lucas: Oh great. Thanks. Yeah. One thing
that kind of sucks in terms of Nexus 7 Specific
development. Is we don't have a X86 emulator
yet for Jellybean.
>>Nick: Mm-hmm.
>>Lucas: So it, yeah, but it gets a bit on
the way because it's just so slow.
>>Nick: Yeah.
>>Lucas: To test stuff there.
>>Nick: Is there any estimate for getting
like a X86 image? I think Intel created it
has 86 images. I mean—
>>Lucas: Oh, OK, it's not Google. Yeah, maybe
that's a stupid question. But maybe and obvious
one. Like, why isn't X86 the primary target
for emulator images? Because that's where
developers are anyway, right?
>>Nick: I guess, well, the answer is in the
[unintelligible] emulator that you were really,
we were really trying to emulate the devices
it was actually running on. So I think the
on base APIs were the vast vast majority of
devices out there. So I think now it was our
primary focus to provide a platform where
people can develop against what it's gonna
run on, on phones. I think that's historically
where we came from. I don't know if that's
gonna change in the future or what. But I
think that's why we are where we are.
>>Lucas: Yeah. I kinda see the point. It's
just that for front-end development most of
the time you don't really care about the architecture.
You just care about seeing how the app feels.
Very quickly. And having a very quick [audio
cuts out, inaudible] is so nice. Like, when
you get the emulator with the X86 image. It's
just makes a big difference.
>>Nick: Yeah.
>>Lucas: maybe that's just me, I don't know.
>>Nick: No, I get your point. Do you ever
use the interface building tools in Eclipse?
>>Lucas: Yeah, I use it. It helps but for
things like animations and stuff, I mean there's
a lot of like back and forth. Just to see,
tweaking and different properties to see how
it builds.
>>Nick: Yeah.
>>Lucas: and for animations, if we had a quick
way to like prereview an animation that would
be nice. But, so like, for now, we just have
to run the application. And see how it goes.
So.
>>Nick: So what do you intend to do? Do you
intend to develop on devices instead?
>>Lucas: Yeah. For Nexus 7 It was interesting
because it didn't have a device while I was
writing the app. So I released the tablet
version. The tablet UI for pattern before
having the device. And I was a bit scared
of like, what could happen because things
like, I was using the new [audio cuts out,
inaudible] so bad on the emulator I couldn't
really see how it worked. So it was a kind
of a really a big guess. Like, that it would
work well. But I wasn't sure. So I was happy
that it did, turned out to be pretty good.
But yeah.
>>Nick: You did a good job of that. So what
tricks, do you got any tricks to tie the optimizing
to the seven, you're using the what, the SW600DP?
>>Lucas: Yeah, yeah. Design wise, I think
the interesting thing about seven inch tablets,
on, I think it's a type of form factor that
is unique in the sense that in portrait and
landscape it behaves very differently. It's
different than tablets. That you have a lot
of space on both orientations. But on seven
inch tablets, on portrait mode, it's almost
like a phone. But not really. And in landscape
mode it's more like a tablet. But smaller.
So it's a kind of a very big, it's a kind
of a gray area type of device. So it's an
interesting exercise in terms of design. So
what I did with Pattern was pretty much blending
the design of the tablet and phones on portrait
mode. So you have a one column thing. But
you have the sidebar.
>>Nick: Yeah.
>>Lucas: But on landscape you have a more
tablet like thing with a grid and the sidebar.
While on phones you only have one column and
that's it. And then I used the sliding tabs
to give access to different tabs of content.
Where, like, sidebars don't work well on phones
anyway. So.
>>Nick: Yeah, exactly. It just isn't enough
horizont. Nice.
>>Lucas: Yeah, yeah. And also, I mean I'm
not really keen on the how do you call it?
Flyout? Menus? The thing that [inaudible]
>>Nick: Well you call it the [unintelligible]
>>Lucas: [unintelligible] Fly-in menu or something?
>>Nick: yeah.
>>Lucas: I have my like, issues with it. I
think it's not discoverable enough. It's--
that's one thing. The other is its kind of
hard to get it right. You have to give it,
give access to it everywhere. Or it feels
weird. Google plus for example, you have to
view home screen to have access to it. So
when you click on the up button you never
know what's going to happen. Is it going to
be on the upper level? Or is it going to be
the flying menu. So it's the same feeling
I got with the Gingerbread type of menus you
had in Android. You don't know what's going
to happen. You don't know if the [inaudible]
menu is the same thing. You don't know if
you slide from the side, will you see it or
not? Like, so.
>>Nick: Right.
>>Lucas: So there's a bit of like unpredictability.
It's just not, not, I think you have to iterate
this thing a bit more to get it right, 'cause
there's a lot of implementations right now,
right?
>>Nick I'm loathe to recommend it to, colleagues
or anyone. Like you I feel like it's stepping
down still. It hasn't really, Markus might
have some thoughts on this as well. Having
implemented it for his app. But yeah, I feel
like we're still trying to work out what the
right way to do it is. At the moment I think
the current feeling is like, the YouTube application's
probably the best example of our current thought.
>>Lucas: Yeah, I agree.
>>Nick: Where it's kind of seeing from the
edge, right. [feedback sounds] replacement
for the dashboard. It's just accessed from
somewhere else.
>>Lucas: Yeah, I don't know, it works well
as a dashboard. But the thing is, depending
on the type of app, you might expect it to
be available everywhere in the app. No matter
in what level of navigation you are. I think
it's possible, Spotify does something like
this.
>>Nick: Yeah.
>>Lucas: So the frame menu is available everywhere.
While in Google plus it's not. So there's
a lot of work to, in terms of like, consolidating
what, how it's supposed to behave. So that
you always have the same behavior.
>>Nick: It might be, it doesn't necessarily
have to be, or shouldn't be available everywhere.
I kind of feel that this ruins any idea of
hierarchy that you have.
>>Lucas: True, true.
>>Nick: So I feel like it should only be available
from, if you think of the dashboard or the
flying menu itself being the first level,
the parent, it should only be available from
direct children of that. It's my feeling.
>>Lucas: Yeah, the only thing is, maybe it's
just a matter of changing the icon or something.
But because Google plus right now has this
thing that looks like it's an up-level kind
of thing, but it's flying menu. And Spotify
changes the icon to be something like menu
looking kind of thing. Maybe that's it. Maybe
it's just about giving the right tense to
the user.
>>Nick: Mm-hmm.
>>Sparky: Yeah, I think that overloading the
exact same UI widget was perhaps a mistake.
The ironic thing is that having that leftward
pointing chevron actually looks more like
it's intended for a fly in menu than it does
for up.
>>Lucas: [chuckles]
>>Nick: My problem is, if you think of the
icon being up, it makes perfect sense. Like
it's the top level of your app. And then you're
kind of going down and [unintelligible] up
a level to get to the root of it. It's just,
I worry that users don't think of it as "up"
'cause it points left. That's my issue.
>>Markus: So it's kind of hard to explain
the concept of up. Or. For us to explain to
users. Like. So, I work for Spotify by the
way. We chose to use the new looking thing.
Like Facebook does, just to make it clear
that this will show, and this is something
that that it [take a lot, that we look about.]
Of likely to use this. I'm not really sure
that, we didn't really want to have to qualify
out. 'Cause if you know, [unintelligible],
so you go back and forth. So it hasn't made
sense for us to always have the menu available
side.
[laughter]
>>Sparky: Yeah, I know that at least from
the perspective of the android UI designers
or UX designers, they're still kind of, they're
still sort of coalescing on their story with
regards to these slide in menus. But the sense
that I get is that they're' not going to go
in a direction of having it available everywhere.
That they're going to recommend restricting
where it's available from.
>>Markus: Well of course it kind of makes
sense based on what kind of application you're
making and how it's working. So I'm not saying
it always should be like that. But--
>>Nick: it still, it's like, a hierarchy to
music there, right? Like you wrote a song
which is part of a playlist or album. Which
is part of a list of albums. I feel like with
the implementation. I get your point about
jumping between different sections. But I
feel like you lose, the cost of that is you
lose any kind of structure. Which I think
people feel a strong attachment to structure.
I think people instantly understand structure.
Being it's how the real world works. And how
we've been trained to think about things for
a long time. So I feel like you kind of lose
that a little bit.
>>Markus: Yeah. But that's kind of hard. I
mean in our case it's kind of easy to do in
some part of the apps. Like artists and albums
created to hierarchy. And, even other user's
playlists and [unintelligible] and so one.
It's kind of hard to put, and [unintelligible]
lists. It also just is problem that, if you
bounce around a lot, and kind of easy to lose
your space. And not be able to go back to
where you lost track. Or it's kind of tricky.
I mean--
>>Nick: [inaudible] type of browsing history.
Which, you know if you'd had to keep on hitting
the back button at all times to you know walk
back along that breadcrumb trail. But Arc
is supposed to be hierarchy which you know,
never really should be that deep.
>>Markus: Yeah. I know. I'm still kind of,
I'm not really sure how to do it.
>>Lucas: Yeah, I think, it depends on how
you see the fly in menu. One way to see it,
which I think it's the case. Like it's how
Spotify implements it. It's more like a jump
list. Instead of a dashboard.
>>Nick: Yeah.
>>Lucas: So it's pretty much about having
a very fast shortcut to go to any of the roots
of navigation in the app. Instead of working
more like a dashboard. I mean, there's a point
about it. The problem with that is, like,
I think the main problem right now is, there
are too many variations of the same pattern.
So I think the important thing is, once you
consolidate that, if it ever appears as a
official API, it should be a always the same.
It shouldn't be like "OK, my app works more
like a jump list. So let's do the global thing.
Oh no, mine is more like a dashboard. Lets'
do the—" Only this will be very confusing.
>>Sparky: I think people are pretty much in
agreement with that sentiment. But because
it is such a fresh new UI feature, that that
consensus hasn't really gelled yet about how
it's going to be.
[pause]
>>Lucas: Yeah, the ratio I see, but I think,
yeah, I totally agree with you. It's pretty
much ongoing. It's something that's still
consolidating. It's, yeah, but it shouldn't
take too long. Because I think it's just spreading
out quite quickly. A lot of people are thinking
that this is great. Let me do it. And then
everyone does differently. And then—
>>Nick: Yeah.
>>Lucas: So I think it would be nice to consolidate
this as soon as possible.
>>Nick: I'm sure we have UX people looking
at it.
>>Sparky: Maybe we could get them to watch
this video and get them straightened out.
>>Markus: I talked to my UX people at Google
IO, we had a session about action bars. And
to us, they actually said they were going
to look at this first thing after Google IO.
So hopefully they're working on it.
>>Nick: I was in the room. I heard that question.
And it got a big round of applause.
>>Sparky: [laughs] I was not in the room but
I saw the video.
>>Nick: Yeah. Adam Powell. The busiest man
at android. Shall we move on from sliding
drawers and app navigation, seeing as it tends
to hijack our—
[laughter]
>>Sparky: Yeah, let's maybe spend a moment
or two looking at W. Long's question about
phone gaps.
>>Nick: Sure.
>>Sparky: It says "I don't know if you have
covered this before. Sorry if you have. But
would you be able to give some comments on
the phone gap framework, as a starting point
for a developer with three to five years of
php and java experience?"
Do you guys wanna take a crack at this one?
Or shall I?
>>Nick: [laughs] I would say, if you've got
java experience, I would urge you to look
at native development.
>>Matt: Yeah, I think having php and java
realistically for you going looking at phone
gap stuff, you're going to be java script
heavy. So you're actually going to be better
off going for the native group with a java
application. And plus you'll get a better
experience at the end. The user being more
happy when they download it from Playstore.
And plus, it's kind of nice, is, you're never
having to wait for the latest feature to be
able to anticipate phone gap framework. There's
lots of kind of massive pros by just going
down the native route to be honest.
>>Nick: Yeah. I have a bunch of problems with
phone gap apps. I've never seen one that I
liked, and I didn't think could be, provide
a better experience if done in native. I think
you get into that uncanny valley trap. Where
something that looks like a button is actually
a link. Basically and anc tag. And you know
it gets a funny highlight. And it doesn't
get the same response. And it's slightly slower
to respond to you. Just think when you're
stacking abstractions on top of abstractions
on top of abstractions. You're going to lose
something. You're going to lose the responsiveness
or the expectations of how an app forms. So
I can understand the arguments for it. Like
you know from the speed of development or
cross platforms, I don't know whatever argument.
I just think if you don't hate your users
then you should perhaps think about going
native.
>>Matt:[laughs] Strong words.
>>Sparky: Wow. Well, I will be the first to
point out that you are in front of a very
biased crowd here.
[laughter]
Since all of us are employed in the business
of convincing you to write the best application
that you can using the native android APIs.
But that said, I've also answered, I've answered
this question in the past couple of days in
stack overflow. And everything that Nick and
Matt said, I agree with. In addition, any
of these so called cross-platform development
frameworks, when you think about it, it's
really a platform in its own right. So you
know, they claim to be right once run everywhere.
But all of the platforms they sit on have
their own little quirks. And you have to still
chase down implementation specific sort of,
little hang-ups that appear. So you still
basically have to write once and test everywhere.
And now because you're using a new platform
that's sitting on top of old platforms, rather
than having to target your application to
N platforms, you'd have to target it to N
plus one. Where the plus one is this cross
platform framework that you're supposedly
writing it in. And then on top of that there's
also, you're stuck in the dilemma of either
you're writing to the least common denominator
across all the platforms that you're deployed
on, or, you're accessing platform specific
features on the host platforms that you're
sitting on. And losing your portability. So
one way or the other, there's not really,
it's not really, it's not really a win. My
general recommendation is to abstract out
your business logic and make it as portable
as you can. Give your business logic a clean
API. And then write the best platform specific
native UI that you can. And have your UI interface
with the API that you defined in your correlogic.
>>Matt: Yeah, I mean one of the other things
that I'd say, is that I think, I was talking
to a developer, he started looking into phone
gap, he was quite excited about it. Showed
me. And I observed that the kit didn't sync
up. I think it was just after Froyo had been
released. Clicked on the camera, opened it
up, and it was a new camera API. And it just
crashed instantly. And it's one of those things.
If you're going down that route. And you're
relying on phone gap to do all of that properly,
you have to then account for the fact that
it doesn't work on certain versions. You've
got to kind of wait for the update to be pushed.
Whereas if you're kind of writing it for yourself,
then I think you get more flexibility around
intent, etcetera. How you implement certain
features. So, yeah. It's one of those things.
It's whether you take control of it or you're
handing it over to another platform which
is another issue. Entirely separate of course.
>>Sparky: A follow-up question from Mr. W.
L. Long. I say "Mr." But I may be wrong. It
says "Would you be able to share some of the
most significant difficulties with dealing
with various screen sizes? And solutions to
it?"
>>Nick: Well, we've had some great tutorials
on just this, if you go to developer.android.com
slash training. There's one called, was it
"Working with different screen sizes?" Managing
different screen sizes. I think the key to
it is a state of mind really. It's how you
approach the development, that you approach
it a bit like a web developer. You know that
there's variation in screen sizes and resolutions
and densities, so you don't go deep down the
hole developing for just like the cell phone
in your pocket and then try to retrofit kind
of support for other things. I think you approach
it from a scaling point of view. So you think,
this bit should be at the top. Then this bit
can grow. And then this bit is at the bottom.
Or however you might arrange it.
So very quickly a few techniques. You can
do, it's like using like relative layouts.
Make it as simple as that. So they can, bits
can grow and change and so on. And always
work in density independent pixels. So it's
a concept in android which allows you to size
things in a way that it'll appear the same
physical size across different density screens.
That's very important. And then to also think
about providing alternative layouts for different
screen sizes. If you look at, I think the
top blog post on the android developers blog,
and my own, in which I wrote about getting
your app ready for Nexus 7 and Jellybean.
That talks about how you can provide alternative
layouts for different devices depending on
how much space they have available to you.
So it lets you write an application with one
piece of logic behind it. But different presentations.
>>Matt: Yeah, I think the one thing I'd add
to that is just try and kind of embrace the
different buckets and if you can sort of use
some different [vents, pictures, the drawable
dash helps. LDPI-NDPI] etcetera. Because that
doesn't just apply to drawboards like Nick
said. It also applies to layouts, and then
valleys. Etcetera. And then you can literally
extract more and more kind of, where those
valleys are coming, and let the system decide
what's the most appropriate valley. If you
kind of erase that, you start getting a lot
of this done for free. And you don't have
to write any additional code.
>>Nick: Yeah, use the resources system.
>>Matt: Yeah.
>>Nick: And you tip some of the people on
the call as well, any top tips on managing
variations and screen sizes?
>>Lucas: One thing that helped me a bit in
Pattern specifically, maybe it's a kind of
extreme approach, but I think in terms of
fragments instead of activities all the time.
>>Nick: Yeah.
>>Lucas: So I started with the phone UI. And
I started with a lot of activities with one
fragment inside most of the time. But then
when I moved on to the tablet UI, I had all
those complements that I could just assemble
in different layouts. So that helped a lot.
So my tip would be, thinking like, fragment,
in terms of fragments from the start. So you
can recombine stuff later.
>>Nick: Absolutely. Yes, great point, should
have said that. Which is, if you're not familiar
with fragments yet, W. L. Long, it's basically
a reusable chunk of functionality. So you
kind of write these chunks and you have them
laid out in different configurations. You
should definitely look at that. In fact, if
you starting from scratch in applications,
you take a look at the new templates which
we have in Eclipse. Then they'll create fragments
for you and so on. So it's a great starting
point.
>>Sparky: Yeah, without writing any code yourself
you can get an application that has two fragments
on screen. One with a list view and another
with a detail.
>>Nick: Well, tablet, on the phone device
it'll be full screen each.
>>Sparky: I think that's quite a step up from
our old Hello World application, I think.
[laughter]
So, uh.
>>Nick: Markus, you have a question incoming
in the Google plus comments. Where Johann
is asking how Spotify app manages to keep
its service running without showing up in
the running services list.
>>Markus: Well, we don't.
>>Nick: That's what I thought the answer would
be. Good.
>>Markus: Well we're not trying to at least.
[laughter]
>>Markus: [static noise and audio cuts out
through this speaking] The way it works, is
we, have a little stealth machine that keeps
track when we're doing something. Which means
[that download we use a unintelligible] there
are a few conditions that can interlock within,
like if you [inaudible] and so on. And if
you're not doing anything, we have a time
out, but it doesn't matter how long it is.
But then you'll actually shut down the service.
And if you don't, if you're actually doing
some things, it will, if you play music without
[unintelligible] identification and thereby
[inaudible] alive. Otherwise you're not doing
anything [inaudible].
>>Nick: Brilliant. I think that's a good tip.
You basically don't do any work you don't
need to do in your services. But make sure
you finish yourself. If you're not doing any
work. Perhaps you know, escape to [a nut]
plate, if the service is running, working
for some condition.
>>Markus: And also it might be run by [unintelligible]
But yeah. So we're actually running off applications
[unintelligible]. So that might be like, seems
to be [inaudible] but it's not.
>>Nick: So, you have a UI in different processes?
>>Markus: The service in UI is different processes.
Yes.
>>Nick: and then you're talking to each other
with AIDL?
>>Markus: Yeah. Exactly.
>>Nick: OK. Hm. OK.
[pause]
>>Markus: I actually have a small question
if there's still time.
>>Sparky: Yeah, go for it.
>>Markus: I saw about Global Juice. The new
version.
>>Sparky: OK.
>>Markus: I saw it yesterday or something.
It looks really cool. Like [unintelligible]
resources. All kinds of stuff. I was wondering,
if any of you have actually tried it out,
and know if it really works well or not. Because
I kind of wanna do it another way if it works.
Because it looks really nice.
>>Nick: I've not tried it. Anyone have?
>>Matt: No, I've seen a couple of places people
playing around with it. Google plus and really
liking it. But yea, I can't say I've really
tried it myself. Yeah.
>>Sparky: I think we've got maybe one or two
sample apps floating around where the engineer
has used Juice to write them. Pretty cool
idea. But likewise I also have not gotten
into it myself yet. I went, its' something
that I would definitely keep in my back pocket
as something I might want to investigate at
some point in the future.
>>Markus: We have some sample apps. Like the
[unintelligible] and it looks really nice.
So. I was having [unintelligible].
[pause]
>>Sparky: Well, I noticed that Juno Gonsalves
was good enough to join us in the Hangout.
And he had a question in the Moderator. We
skimmed over it pretty quickly. But since
he was good enough to join us here I thought
maybe we would revisit that. So he was, do
you wanna ask the question yourself?
>>Juno: Er, I think that everything was right.
And so there is no need to clarify it further.
But well, I can repeat the, what he was asking.
Well, I just started doing some development
with NFC APIs. For the contact last smart
cards. And well, at first thing, I've already
published that issue. Is that I think that
Jellybean is not supporting NFC B. Transit
always failed. I published an issue, it wasn't
common, the app. But I guess that is an issue
with jellybean. But NFC B is completely dead
for now. It's not possible to talk with the
text. And well, all the rest in the NFC support,
I think it's more oriented for the standard
text. For the M-def. And not for the technologies
to talk directly in raw format with the text.
So the special documentation is not that good.
And I just lost a lot of time and that was
well, actually I didn't place any question.
[laughs] My only question is that if there
was any book I could look at. Because the,
my issue for example this morning was to try
to talk with the text. And, I'm stalled. And
my face will stall, I'm not sure if my ftp
was or not. And I just lost the entire morning
trying to talk in [igrate]. Which, OK, yeah,
I see the book. [laughs] In [igrate] with
the tag. And my conclusion is that the stack
just doesn't allow it. So. Yeah. Probably
I will take this suggestion and try to look
at that book.
>>Nick: Like you say, I think it's quite orientated
around doing NDEF.
>>Juno: yeah.
>>Nick: Definitely. 'cause we see that as
the most common use case. The most useful
use case. But you still do can do all the
tech stuff. You still can read the raw bytes
and so on. That's definitely supported use-case.
>>Juno: Well, like I was telling, for example,
NFC B is completely dead in Jellybean. At
least on Nexus S. The NFC B, so, one of the
technologies for text is not working. Uh,
I just found that issue a few days ago.
>>Nick: It used to work on ICS and it's regressed?
[pause]
>>Juno: Yeah, my connection is bad, I'm not
getting it.
>>Nick: Sorry, I was just asking, it used
to work on ICS and it's regressed? But sounds
like a bug. Have you filed that?
>>Juno: Well, no idea because I just started
now with Jellybean and I just have one phone.
But, yeah, I receive an exception saying that,
something not supported. Operation not, well,
technology not supported. So I'm pretty sure
it's a regression. Because no one was claiming
that before.
>>Nick: Interesting.
>>Juno: Yes.
>>Nick: Sounds like a bug, so that—
>>Juno: Yeah, it's for sure an issue. I don't
see—
>>Nick: Yeah, so if you go to source.android.com
there'll be instructions there on how to file
a bug, so if you could file it as a bug, that's
the right way to go ahead with this.
>>Juno: Yeah, actually I think, well it's
on uh, it's, I guess it's this one. Just well,
just a moment. I think—
>>Nick: A bug already filed, you're saying.
>>Juno: Well, it's like this. This is my,
the bug I filed, this is the correct place.
>>Nick: Oh, OK. I just thought it was target.
>>Juno: Yeah, but this is the right place
to file issues?
>>Sparky: Yeah.
>>Matt: Yeah. I see. Yeah.
>>Juno: OK. OK. So it's just that. Thanks
for the book suggestion.
>>Sparky: I remembered where I saw it. I think
somebody in my Google plus stream is the author
of it, and said "Hey look I just published
this book." Or something like that. I think
that's where I might have seen it.
>>Matt: Ah.
>>Juno: OK.
>>Nick: Ok. Right.
>>Juno: OK. Very nice.
>>Nick: I think we've run out of time. Sorry
we started a little late. We had a little
setup issue here. But thank you everyone for
joining us. And we'll be back, same time next
week, talking android development. So until
then, you know—
>>Sparky: Now, next week I will be in London
and we will all be involved in a developer
activity. So it will be interesting to find
out what shape the hangout takes. Maybe we
can get some other people on screen with us.
What do you think?
>>Matt: yeah, that sounds fun. Let's just
fill up all of these seats with people.
[laughter]
>>Nick: Well, until next week. Yeah. Feel
free to fire your questions into the Moderator.
And we can take a look at them. Or turn up
next week, and ask them live. So thanks everyone
for coming.
>>Matt: Cheers. Bye.
>>Nick: Bye.